this is Startalk Joshua white from
Facebook he wants to know hey bill when
do you think GMOs will be used to
bioremediation tama native areas like
plants that are specifically designed to
draw up heavy metals out of soil or
bacteria that can clean up underground
aquifers contaminate it with solvents
that's a great idea and so the the place
to start with that making let's say in
this case bacteria that could metabolize
oil in an oil spill okay now we're
talking some serious money here I love
the way you're thinking so that would be
a really cool application however can we
do that cuz I'd need some money because
that would be great so are you in the
oil spill cleanup business no but I will
be so this is a good example of a place
where maybe you could take the organic
chemicals and Oregon organic chemicals
or chemicals that come from organisms
which nominally have carbon that's what
organic chemistry is and you could have
some bacteria that could metabolize that
and then leave behind all the other
stuff that comes out of oil well sulfur
and so on and let it sink to the bottom
of the ocean or metabolize that too and
make it into some amazing plastic or I
have it all stick together and a big in
a big oil tar sheet that is much easier
to lap up with your oil tar sheets
lapping up ship yeah your oil tar bounty
yeah all right so this would be an
example of something that I mean a place
to start as far as taking heavy metals
out of the soil that's okay then you got
to put process those plants that might
be a fine thing so now like a landfill
so when you place where you want to
build a condominium but you just pulled
the stuff out of the soil and then
uproot the trees and then use them for
something else and then build your
condos right there without having the
children at risk of being around all
these heavy metals gotcha that's a
Grammy it's a fine idea I am NOT in that
business and I got a feeling though
there's somebody who is man those guys
at Monsanto
based I'm not saying it's all about
Monse
okay everybody please but they spend two
million dollars a day on R&D on research
a day see and almost a hundred million
dollars a year on research not on not on
shipping their products just on research
okay and that's I think they're a victim
of their own success and I know the
feeling look at you and me Chuck right
we're victims of our own success because
we've been so fascinating in this first
segment of star talk radio that it's all
we're out of time so stay tuned we'll be
right back it's Chuck nice and Bill
Nighy you're listening to Startalk this
is Startalk